hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
die leckersten kekse die ich in meinem
ganzen leben hier gegessen habe ich
zeige euch später noch warum und das
sind so genannte monte carlos spanische
mandl kekse die werden in spanien ganz
typisch zur weihnachtszeit gebacken
jetzt zeige ich euch zuallererst die
zutaten wir benötigen mail gemahlene
mandeln außerdem butter und da ist es
besser wenn sie zimmer warm ist zucker
den abrieb und den saft einer halben
zitrone und zimt wir beginnen
zuallererst damit das mehl und die
mandeln an zu rüsten und ja ihr habt
richtig gehört wir rüsten tatsächlich
auch das mail an das ist ganz erheblich
für den geschmack das macht einen
riesenunterschied macht die fahne am
besten nicht ganz so heiß der herd ist
bei mir hier auf mittlerer stufe und
jetzt müsste ich das ganz langsam an in
dem ich das immer wieder hin und her
schiebe
hier seht ihr dass die mandel mail
mischung etwas dunkler geworden ist vom
anrösten jetzt ist es genau richtig und
ich gebe das inm eine separate schüssel
damit es vollständig abkühlen kann
es ist ganz wichtig dass die mandel mail
mischung komplett ausgekühlt er
weitermacht sie darf also auch nicht
lauwarm sein dann kommen die restlichen
zutaten damit hinein also einmal zucker
und zimt und hier habe ich noch den saft
einer halben zitrone
die schale kann ich da leider nicht
verwenden denn das ist keine bio zitrone
die ist nicht unbehandelt die gab es in
meinem supermarkt leider nicht falls sie
eine bio zitrone habt dann nimmt bitte
gerne auch den schalen abrieb davon dann
gebt ihr noch die zimmer warme butter
mit dazu und knetet das mit den händen
so lange bis sich alles miteinander
verbunden hat
ihr werdet merken dass wir keinen
einheitlichen oder geschmeidigen teig
bekommen dass es eher so eine krümelige
masse der gebe ich mir dann auf die
arbeitsfläche und versuch sie dann so
gut wie möglich zu einer einheit
zusammen zu kneten und zusammen zu
drücken damit ich sie dann ausstechen
kann und auch das ist ein geheimnis
warum die kekse so unfassbar zart und
möbel sind wir haben kein zur bindung im
teig oder ähnliches wir versuchen jetzt
die masse einfach mit den händen so
zusammen zu drücken dass wir ein
zentimeter oder eineinhalb zentimeter
große kekse herausdrücken können das
ausstechen ist gar kein problem anders
als man jetzt vielleicht vermutet hätte
die kekse lassen sich wunderbar
ausstechen gehen auch nicht kaputt und
man kann sie direkt aufs backblech legen
nachdem dann der gesamte tag
ausgestochen wurde und aufs backblech
gelegt wurde am besten mit einem
backpapier runter gebt ihr sie erst für
zehn minuten in den kühlschrank und dann
direkt in den backofen bei 170 grad ober
und unterhitze für ca 17 minuten bis sie
so schön gold frauen sind nach dem
auskühlen habe ich sie dann mit
geschmolzener vollmilchpulver türe
verziert das ist natürlich vollkommen
euch überlassen und dann lasse ich sie
nochmal aushärten und dann sind die
kekse auch schon fertig
falls ihr nun alle schritte beachtet
keine zutaten austausch sondern ganz
genau so zubereitet wie es euch im video
gezeigt habe dann erhaltet ihr die wohl
leckersten kekse dieser welt die kekse
sind nämlich sehr fein mürbe und
aromatisch durch das anrösten des mehls
und der mandeln und ihr dürft auch auf
keinen fall den zitronensaft weglassen
denn der macht auch einen erheblichen
unterschied im nachgeschmack
falls euch jetzt auch interessiert wie
denn der geschmack dieser kekse ist und
er sie gerne nachbacken möchtet dann
schaut gern mal in die infobox da habe
ich alle genauen mengenangaben für euch
aufgeschrieben und ich bin sehr sehr
gespannt auf euer feedback wenn ihr sie
dann probiert habt falls ihr nichts mehr
verpassen möchte dann abonniert gern
meinen kanal und ich sag bis zum
nächsten mal auf die keys kitchen